all right so I'm done now my question to
you is and this is the most important
step to complete the square this is the
critical step here now my question to
you is why did that work why did the
magic the magic phrase is hard that
number and then square it harder than
the square why does that do anything why
is that useful any suggestions yes okay
so what you're trying to do I guess if
I'm understand you correctly say is we
try to reverse-engineer this does that
make sense like you guys are really good
at things right so you can sort of
imagine all right if I was reverse
expanding okay what would I have to add
to this in order to have that factorize
right however there is a better way to
understand why it's randomly having and
squaring and if you are not sick of me
doing these things yet then get ready
because I'm going to show this to you
visually maybe you want to get a ruler
out for this part because it'd be really
useful
this is where we began do you remember
the first thing that we did before we
actually completed the square is we
rewrote it my son
you remember that now what I want to do
is just like I prove to you why a plus B
or square is not a square plus B Square
in fact it's a squared plus 2 a B plus B
spread okay so this is how we drew that
how would you draw this just think about
it for a second I will show you we've
done this a few times now right we did
it further differences well we did it
for a few different kinds of situations
how am i treat for suggestion yeah
yeah yeah so if I think about like this
X square X square is like one of these
shapes here well as the name suggests
cuz no one reads this is next to the
power of two it's going to be a square
yeah so I'm gonna draw this guy here as
a square so he's x squared it's X 2 by X
now that's what x-ray looks like keep in
mind I don't know how big or small this
square is the whole point is that X can
be anything what might this look like 6x
now pom pom is got a scale on here so
I've got to use a little bit of license
creatively I'm gonna say if this is X
square then 6x is kind of like what it's
six times X right well if x times X
gives you a square then six times X will
give you like a rectangle right now in
the case where X was six it would also
be a square but you don't know that X
could be anything so I'm going to draw
it like this
like so right imagine this is x over
here they're the same here and here
I don't really know how long it is in
comparing to see so I'm just gonna make
that on length there do you agree that
that rectangle is six next okay with
that
all right so faster now that's just one
half of the equation on the other half
I've got eleven for reasons of become
clear in a second I don't really care
how big eleven is I'm gonna scream to
remember there now I want you to think
what was that magic thing we did to turn
this into something we could factorize
we harder harder and then we square it
right now I want you to think back to
when we did all these constructions
right sometimes you can pull something
out like this one do you remember this
one that makes the construction
more useful okay now
hobby hobby if I gave you a cake and it
was like a rectangle like this
having it would just be slicing across
the middle do you agree forgive you to
pieces
okay so on the next line we didn't write
this before but I want to visualize it
on the next slide I'm going to do a
hobby like that do you agree that's just
taking that rectangular cake and slicing
it okay now what does it look like he's
x squared nothing's changed like what
have I got now instead of that one long
six x well I've got this one that's 3x
do you agree and then I have another one
that's also 3x so far so good and then
of course I've got the right I'm gonna
need a little more space but we'll get
there now what's the point
I wonder if your gears are turning yet
do you remember with this I had to do
another kind of slicing thing like this
in fact I think if you recall something
like this there was my a squared minus B
squared
do you recall big squared take away a
little square
what's that slice off yeah this part
over here I said hey cut him off right
let him do that what was the point
because I moved it around remember he
came around like this remember that and
so he is you're a plus B that we were
searching for that wasn't in the diagram
okay so I sliced it off so I could move
it okay look
look you've got two pieces now 3x and 3x
we're cruising
is what I'm gonna suggest these both
these rectangles they both have like X
right that means that just like here see
these legs here they should match up to
this one should bear because that's X as
well yeah so I'm gonna do that I'm going
to move one over so I'm gonna take say
this one down be I'm just gonna jam it
up against the bottom moment is that
okay
now don't forget this is on X hi
why sorry this is X hi and this is how
high again okay
yeah this guy down he went across what
we're gonna do with this guy well just
like with this before I put it on to
anything I'm going to turn it around
because this is X here right so I'm just
gonna stick it over here is that okay
do you agree that I could put the 3x
there instead if I shift it around what
was the width of that rectangle again
the width is down to three do you agree
now it looks to me like I have something
that's kind of like an I don't know what
would you call it may be an incomplete
square do you agree and so all it needs
is something to be added to it right
what do you add well will you add 9
don't you why is it not because it's
because of course it's not because it's
three times three so you Oh surprise
surprise you completed this square does
that make sense right now I know why
it's fun
you say why I'm obsessed with names
because if you really understand why
something is called what it is then you
understand it about okay now that's the
nine you've completed the square but of
course you've got to add something to
the other side as well
I don't really care what it is but this
is a square that's now 20 be its square
so how big are the legs
it's squid the area area is 20 so the
sideline is now as neat as that was
right
that X plus 3 equals root 20
I will admit one shortcoming of this is
that what I'm missing half the solutions
are time what's the other solution right
and this is the way greeks used to do
all the VMS right which is why Greeks
have no need for negative numbers all of
their maths came out of geometry like
you know Pythagoras okay but this is why
completing the square does its thing
okay